hey what's up my name is Samuel lids and
on this video I want to talk about
shared ownership you know when you see
on Rightmove those houses where you
think oh my gosh that's so cheap and
then it says 50% shared ownership what
does that mean what that means is you're
buying a part of the house and the other
part is going to be continued to be
owned by a Housing Association so is it
good should you buy a house want to
share ownership basis or not I guess the
answer it kind of depends generally
speaking I think shared ownership is bad
I am NOT a fan and I'm going to list the
reasons why but I'm also going to give
the pros as well and then you can make
your own mind up but first we really
important is you cannot buy a house on a
shared ownership scheme and then rent it
out if you're buying a house on a shared
ownership scheme you have to live there
this is set up for first-time buyers
that haven't got much money and they can
only afford to put in 50 percent or 25
percent usually is between 25 and 75
percent the reason I think is bad for
homeowners number one being a homeowner
isn't that great being a homeowner is
not that great I myself and a tenant
this house that I'm in right now I live
here but it's not owned by me and that's
a commercial decision and the reason is
is because I like being a tenant because
if something breaks and I'm in a big
house the landlord fixes it it's easy my
properties that I own and I rent out
they make me good money because I buy
them strategically not to live in now
the problem of shared ownership houses
is you buy it to live in but you have
all the cons of being a homeowner isn't
they if you say I'm 50% shared ownership
owner of this house the boiler breaks
you don't go 50/50 on the repairs you
have to pay 100% so you have the cons of
being a homeowner but you also are a
tenant because if you only own 50
percent of the house you need to pay
rent on the other 50% to the Housing
Association which a lot of people don't
realize but you you're still a tenant
firstly every time you buy more shares
you have to pay legal sister fees
mortgage application fees and then even
if you buy all the shares and suddenly
you own the whole house it's only ever
gonna be leasehold which means you never
own the land which means you're always
going to have to pay service charges to
the freeholder owns the land I am NOT a
fan of shared ownership at all another
thing is this if
you invest 10 grand on a house say
you're living in the shed ownership
house usually they're new builds by the
way and normally you'll pay over the
odds
so normally you'll pay 50 percent but
it'll be an inflated price and then if
you want to sell the house you have to
sell the shares it's pretty difficult to
sell because it's such a terrible scheme
so you're probably going to end up being
stuck with it and there's many people
saying it's not a terrible scheme I did
share ownership and make money yeah
because you bought a house and houses
often go up in value so I'm not saying
you can't make money of share ownership
I'm just saying it's a very very very
sucky scheme it sucks
I'd never let my kids buy a house on
shared ownership if you have s 10 grams
I'm getting a new kitchen a new bathroom
and lifting the value of the house up so
you invest 10 grand you push the house
up 10 grand but then you only benefit
from half of that five grand so it's
just like it does not make any sense so
my general thoughts are if you're
scrolling through Rightmove and you see
share ownership house keep on scrolling
love to know your thoughts comment your
thoughts below if you enjoy these types
of videos some master like them don't
forget to subscribe and turn on the
notification bow I did another video
about help to buy scheme if you're
interested in that video you can check
it out right here if you say Samuel
what's the alternative how do I make
money as a property investor then come
on down to the property investors crash
course you can do that right here and of
course don't forget subscribe over here
thanks so much I'll see you next time